after the coffee phase I think you start
with the second part of the scheduling
session that's being given by a BB song
Caltech and I think how do we talk more
about the bridge between competitive or
rather versus and stochastic analysis
through the robust efficient Thanks
so yeah so as Nikhil said I mean this
these are two fields that are some sense
really related really close they work on
exactly the same problems but in other
sense are very disparate there's very
few people that publish in both of them
there's very few connections between
them and and so our talks are kind of
you know examples of the few connections
that we know of between these fields and
how you can try to exploit those and so
Nikhil did you know the quick background
and one example of this connection where
you tried to get a best of both worlds
from you know taking a worst-case
analysis and porting it over to the
stochastic setting and I'm gonna try to
focus on two other examples where in
different ways the results from the two
fields kind of informing each other and
can actually combine to get something
different than either field was doing
alone and so the perspective behind
these combinations in the second part is
really about robustness versus
optimality and this is the way that I
view these two fields so you know when
you when you're doing a competitive
ratio you know you talk about optimality
of the competitor ratio but really
you're trying to say this is the most
robust policy in some sense it's it's
the best worst case bound you could get
so these are robustness bounds and if
you're doing well if you give an example
of a policy that has a good competitive
ratio it's a it's a robust policy it may
not be optimal for the particular
situation you're using it in but it's
going to be very robust and the
perspective in the stochastic community
the queuing community is a little
different it's saying let we know
something about our situation we can
model it and now let's try to actually
write down what the optimal policy would
be for that particular setting for those
particular model assumptions and so
really the focus is on optimality
and rather than robustness but of course
both are important in practice and and
sometimes they're aligned so the SRPT
example that Nikhil gave is something
where your optimal and robust right your
one competitive so so they're really
perfectly aligned but in most cases
they're not so the the blind examples
that Nikhil gave are cases where they're
really not so aligned on the surface
right so if you want to be robust rmlf
this policy that he talked about at the
end is the best most robust policy or
you get this log end guarantee but if
you want to be optimal rmlf is not
optimal if you know that the workload
you know the job sizes are Pareto you
should do a CT f this is provably
optimal in a queueing model if you know
that the workload is light tailed you
should do first-come first-serve this is
provably optimal in a stochastic model
and so there's a distinction there's a
contrast between the type of policy you
should do use if you're trying to be
robust across all the workloads versus
if you're trying to be optimal for a
particular we're good
and I think you know this this
difference in perspective is what drives
a lot of the different questions and the
different styles of results that the two
communities go after so I'll try to
connect those in this talk with two
examples and and I guess like I said
these are these are two examples now
they're the only ones I know of
partially that's because I've worked in
both of these areas but I also know the
queueing literature pretty well and
there's really very few places where
there's a strong connection so I'd love
to find other connections and part of
you know us doing this tutorial I on a
pom asked us to do it is that hopefully
during this semester we can find other
places where there are connections
between these two large robust
literature's but in these two there's in
some sense success stories and the idea
I guess you know to give the kicker
first is you know Nikhil showed how to
get the best of both worlds this first
example you know take a queueing take a
worst-case result and poured it over to
ask astok result the first example here
is going to basically show how you can
try to combine results from the two
fields to actually get an explicit
trade-off results that can quantify how
much you suffer in term
robustness to get optimality and
vice-versa and how you can kind of
optimize combinations of the two and the
second one is going to work at look at a
place where scheduling is just a really
hard task and there are lots of
inefficiency hardness sorts of
guarantees and the idea is to show that
you can get a lot of insight into what's
leading to these guarantees by combining
the stochastic in the worst case
viewpoint so I I kind of I dabble you
know I have a side of me that's a system
side so you'll have to bear with I
actually have motivation slides for
models so sorry I'll go quickly but the
the first the first little example is
power
and you know energy is important at all
levels of systems these days so you know
power is why we have multi-core battery
life is important I've done a lot of
work in data centers and energy and so I
could give you lots of fun statistics
there but maybe the kicker is you know
electricity usage of data centers is
growing ten times faster than the rest
of our energy usage and so we need to do
something perfect but anyway I'll skip
over that the the takeaway is you know
the old perspective and scheduling and
these sorts of things and all of these
levels in computer systems was just
faster is better and nowadays there's an
increasing willingness to trade off
speed straight off how quickly you're
doing things with how much energy you're
using to do them and why this trade-off
exists is because basically the faster
you run a system the more power it uses
and there tends to be some convex
relationship between power and speed and
so you pay an increasing cost to run
faster and this is you know where you
sit on this is an optimization that
you're making to trade-off energy and
performance and so speed scaling is the
generic term that you use to capture
this so you can dynamically adjust the
speed of your system as it's running to
trade-off how quickly you're serving
jobs with how much energy you're using
and you know naturally you'd say you
know if there aren't too many jobs
around you can run slower if there's a
lot of jobs around you should run
quicker because you're incurring a lot
of costs you know every job is including
extra delay so you run faster when
there's a lot of jobs there so there's a
natural sort of way you would want to go
about doing this and this is something
that happens in different
at all levels of systems so and you know
it chips its voltage or frequency
scaling disks and spin-down and park and
run at different speeds Wireless you
have dynamic transmission power which
changes depending on what jobs are
present and how you use it all the way
up to data centers where you change the
number of servers that are active the
number of racks that are in power saving
modes etc depending on the workloads
that are present and so this is sort of
a very generic thing and you can think
of studying this at its core as just a
very simple scheduling queueing type
question where you have a server with
jobs arriving to it and you need to
dynamically figure out not just how to
schedule the jobs but also what speed to
run the server at how many servers to
have a hot new you or some things like
this but you know when one sever just
what speed to write it out so this is
the speed scaling decision and of course
it's very intertwined with the
scheduling decision right so scheduling
will tell you how many jobs are there
and how many jobs there is gonna impact
how you should scale the speed of
yourself ok ok so the question now you
know for doing speed scaling you're
dynamically controlling your speed
you're doing this to balance energy and
performance so we have to have some
metric that combines these sort of the
the main one I guess the initial one
that people have studied the most and
this is you know across our as well as
in computer science it's just a linear
combination so you take a weighted
combination of your I'm using T for
response time or flow time just like
Nikhil did so you take a weighted
combination of that and the energy that
use of course there's lots of other
measures that you could study as well
you could take you know a constrained
version where you're minimizing flow
time subject to an energy constraint you
could take you know the opposite where
you minimize energy subsets subject to
deadlines or QoS constraints for your
jobs and basically all of them have been
studied to some extent and there are
lots of open questions remaining on all
of them but you know you name your
measure somebody's looked at it to some
extent at this point and it's you know
these sorts of models have been studied
since the mid-90s basically
and you know I guess I should say you
know I'm assuming everybody knows energy
but energy is power over time so so you
when you start to think about what this
measure looks like and to drill down
into this model a little bit more you're
you have this power function and just
practical guy here's real data from real
processors that we we measured and you
know there's lots of versions of this
but basically if you look on a log-log
scale things look rather linear which
means that when you're thinking of chips
a polynomial is a pretty good model for
what this power associated with the
speed looks like disks have a similar
sort of polynomial Wireless you get
something exponential but you know it
doesn't matter just think of this as
something convex now for this talk I'll
assume everything's nice and continuous
and easy but of course in reality
there's often discrete states and again
you know there's lots of papers that
have looked at the discrete versions of
these problems so don't take my you're
talking about that for meaning that it
doesn't this okay so that's our simple
model and now if we think of you know
what what might happen in this let's
just look at some examples so the
simplest example is batch job arrivals
so suppose you just have n jobs arrive
you know I'll order them in terms of
their size and there's nothing else
that's gonna come what do you do you're
gonna try to schedule them in some order
well everything from the previous two
talks should say we should put the small
job first but now how should we
determine the speeds we should probably
run quicker at the beginning then at the
end because at the beginning while we're
working on the smallest job there are n
minus 1 jobs waiting behind us and so
we're paying all of them are paying cost
while we're waiting and then we sort of
slow down a little bit as we finish the
jobs but what should those things be so
just you know first order optimization
it's not just intuitive that you should
use SOP T if you think about it for a
minute you can prove to yourself that if
effort if SRPT was optimal for a single
server then here again it's optimal
because imagine fixing your speeds
whatever 2 speeds you decide to use fix
them and now a circuit e will be the
optimal thing to do the other simple
thing to convince yourself of is the
speeds shouldn't
in between moments when you complete the
jobs you know there's no there's no
incentive to change that the optimal
will have constant speed in between the
job completion moments in your system
and once you rank those you can actually
just write down the cost so you can
write down the combination of the cost
as you know for the first job I'm gonna
run at some speed s n so SN is the
smallest one it's gonna take X and Ty X
n over SN time during that time I'm
gonna be incurring speed power P of SN
sorry this is kind of the response time
for the first job the power for the
first job the second job has to wait for
the first job to complete and then it
gets to go it takes this power while
it's going and so on right so you can
just write it down nice and easily then
you know the nice next observation is
you can factor out all the sizes so the
sizes don't matter all that matters for
the optimal speeds in this example is
the number of jobs that are present
makes things a lot a little bit easier
to think about and then you can actually
figure out what the optimal thing would
be so to keep the formula simple take
polynomial and near then your optimal
speeds for this example turn out to be
this alpha root of an over alpha minus
one which when you think about it is
really nice because it's saying that the
power so if there are n jobs in the
system the speed that you should run at
is so that the power you're incurring is
proportional to the number of jobs
present so in some sense you should
balance the delay penalty the number of
jobs that are being subject to delay
while you're there proportionally with
the power that you're willing to run it
and this is something that is a pretty
clean observation and on the system side
it's something that this is a paper from
Google that was back in the early 2000s
that really made a call for the
community to try to use energy
proportional computing they you know
they weren't using this model to do this
they were just saying this is a nice
thing we should be able to have systems
that run with you know one tenth of the
power and energy if we're running at
one-tenth of the load you know this was
something that they really called for
and you know it's it aligns with what
theory says here but it's not always
optimal this was one little example so
the next simplest example the
you look at when you're thinking of
scheduling problems is instead of a
batch of periodic arrivals so one job
arrive every one second so let's have a
job of size one arrive everyone over our
seconds again we'll keep myself et but
it doesn't matter because the optimal
should just be doing finishing
everything before the next job of rhymes
so you run just fast enough at radar so
that you finished the first the job that
you have before the next job arrive so
every job waits one you're always
incurring this power just to make things
simple I'll look at the cost per job Sol
normalized by our and then if we were to
do energy proportional scaling for this
we'd be in some sense screwed right
because before we could get up to
running at radar we'd have to let our
jobs queue up right our P of our jobs
Cuba you know if we're gonna be it's
going to be use you know if it's gonna
be worth it for us to run incurring
power our then we have to have P of our
jobs waiting that's what the idea of
energy proportionality is and so that
means that you're already giving up a
factor of two in this really simple case
because now you're you know if PR jobs
waiting for you and you're using time PR
so you're off by a factor of two and
what is you know probably the easiest
case to schedule just but despite that
energy proportional scaring always is
pretty close to optimal and it's
something where this this idea SRPT p
inverse of n was proposed by a Kirk Cruz
and co-authors back in 2003 just without
an analysis at first actually
and then basically in the next seven
years the competitive ratio was
generalized so you know initially the
results started for unit size jobs and
pilot in quadratic power functions then
I went to Tallinn Emil power functions
and went to general jobs and so on and
so forth and finally you know the the
end of the day you got down to the two
for general power functions not even
smooth convex just general power
functions and and arbitrary size jobs so
some sense you know this policy matches
it's lower bound in that previous
example but you know it's even that I
guess better than that in some sense in
that there's no policy that can do
better than that so it's not just where
the progression ins for SRPT
and this energy proportional scaling
there's no long line policy well I
should hedge this is one of my results
so I can criticize it it's we have a
really ugly condition here on the
algorithms that I'd love for somebody to
remove so so we can show that basically
no natural algorithm can do better than
a factor of two and this is one of those
kludgy proofs where we can show it for
any policy that's going to serve one job
at a time or any policy that has speeds
that grow slower or faster or
proportional to asymptotically but you
know some sort of weird oscillation in
the speeds asymptotically meit's
theory be better but you know that the
thing is so yeah so we get this too and
so if we interpret this result basically
you see that you know compared to the
non energy case you can't be optimal
anymore you have to give up something
but you don't actually have to give up
that much and it's a very simple
intuitive idea of the speed scaling that
when combined with optimal scheduling
gets you there yeah and and actually the
the proof of this theorem kind of builds
on the two examples that I just showed
so those two examples are enough to show
you know no policy can do well for those
two examples
okay so that's kind of the baby version
of speed scaling and there's lots of
ways that it is and can should continue
to be pushed so lots of other ways you
can imagine balancing energy and
performance going from single to multi
server systems going to more complex
models of scaling where you taken to
temperature and and more detailed models
of what the system might be what the
power function might look like but to
connect with what Nikhil was talking
about I want to focus a little bit on
these non-chlorine these blind policies
because there we had this and they you
know he talked about there being this
hard bound where non clarify policies
couldn't do better than log and
competitive and here that goes away the
you know the the fact that you can pay
attention to energy actually gets you
makes the problem easier for blind
policies to do well and in some sense
this is a connection to the resource
augmentation results that he was
mentioned so you know if with the blind
policies he mentioned that if you give
them a little bit extra capacity they
can do much better and well if we're
willing to sacrifice a little energy we
can give blind policies a little extra
capacity and so that trade-off is worth
it and you can sort of make up for
policies that aren't quite as good by
paying a little bit in the energy cost
so the nice thing is the same speed
scaling actually lets you do this so you
don't even have to change the speeds
going you can still stick with energy
proportional speed scaling and then non
clairvoyant policies can do very well so
the first result on this form was from
China and preusse and I think Nikhil was
might have been on that too and they got
a 2 alpha squared over long alpha and
then you know at the end of a bunch of
results we have one that's four four
alpha minus two I think that's the best
known among the blind policies right now
but there's not a tight lower bound yet
what you know is that there's no blind
policy that can be constant independent
of alpha here so as alpha goes to
infinity blind policies all do very
badly but you don't I don't think we
have a tight lower bound certainly not
one that matches the for alpha case but
the nice thing about this result I think
compared to the previous ones is is that
it's for a very common policy so so
pS processor sharing is this round-robin
like policy that nikhil talked about and
it's something that's really often the
model that people use for systems in
practice it's a very it's a very typical
kind of scheduling policy and and it
does very well and it's one that
connects very nicely with queuing
results which we'll see in a second and
like I said already this is this is a
nice comparison because in Pia in the
non-energy case you know when we just
cared about flow time yes was order and
over log n so basically order n
competitive so as bad as possible and
all of a sudden with a little extra you
know speed based on the speed scaling it
can get down and be small constant
competitive so for the realistic case
you know alpha is about two and chips
and so this would be you know six
competitive and again like the other
case there's lots of interesting results
here but I don't want to dwell on that
because I want to get to the connection
so that's kind of the story about speed
scaling from a robustness perspective
and here you know things don't
completely align because we're not
getting one competitive results we're
getting policies that are very robust
they have constant competitive ratios
but there's a natural question of can
you actually be optimal in a stochastic
model and how do the policies that are
optimal in stochastic models when you're
willing to make assumptions about the
workload connect to policies in the
worst case mode so you know here we have
this idea that this kind of speed
scaling works well but over here so
basically you know the model now just
changes very slightly so instead of you
know having no assumptions on the
workload we throw in our mg one so we
have a plus on arrival we have job sizes
that are generally distributed we have
some load and we have the same objective
and here actually this becomes if you if
you look at PS where we where we ended
on the previous section this becomes a
real textbook stochastic control problem
you can pick up any intro control Theory
you know book and one of the examples
when they're doing MD piece will be this
problem so and it's a nice problem
because you write down a very simple
Markov chain for PS this is exactly the
one the top path looks exactly like but
Nick
had on his slides and now the only
difference is the bottom half instead of
all being Meuse is your controllable
speed so so this is your these are your
control variables that you're trying to
optimize and you're trying to minimize
this cost by setting those right down
the MDP use whatever numerical tool you
want
solve it done right so this is this is
the way the textbooks give it to you if
we want to try to connect it to the
worst-case results we have to do a
little bit more because we have to
actually get structural results about
the form of the policies that result and
that turns out to be pretty grungy but
you can do it so this is our best
attempt at it and the the middle line so
this is mg 1 this is processor sharing
this is the quadratic case to keep it
simple enough to put on a slide although
we have the general and you know this
middle line isn't so interesting the
relevant one is this bottom one where if
you look at it asymptotically you get
rho plus root n and remember this is the
quadratic case so this root n is P
inverse this root n is energy
proportional scale yeah so think about
it as when I wrote down that example I
normalized it per job think about
normalizing it per job
yeah so no so here that's a good point
so here ro I don't care about it being
less than one because whatever ro
whatever the arrival rate is and the job
size is or rival rate times job size is
my ro the speeds are monotonically
increasing so it just means that you'll
go up and have an occupancy high enough
that it stabilizes so there's no
instability here whatever the RO is as
long as your speeds increase to infinity
you'll stabilize it matters okay and so
you can get this and the you know the
nice thing about this is that we have
this result which provides a pretty
strong connection to the or you know I
guess is superficial but a you know
direct connection to the worst case
because we have this you know additive
thing where you have the load which is a
very stochastic component combining with
exactly what you would suggest from the
worst case perspective for this model
and I mean I should say that there
there's a big difference here in the
sense that for small and Rudin is not
the right thing for this decosta model
but for a large and B then which is you
know asymptotically you're growing it
root in and this is what the worst case
model suggested for this case
yeah and the nice thing is so this is PS
and this is mg one you can push this so
there's been a couple of papers now that
have done Gigi with fluid type scalings
for other policies and basically once
you go to a fluid type scaling where
then the policy doesn't matter too much
and you can get rid of these assumptions
but but you it's an approximate model
and you basically get exactly this
asymptotic form for other policies more
general models no so
Nikhil had it on his slide alright so
fluid scaling so basically it's a way of
looking at a Brownian motion
approximation for what the queuing
system looks like I mean that you can
think about that you think
yeah I'll say something about that a
second yeah so okay so coming to this
now I'm gonna actually have a plot on a
slide about some results so if we look
at this we have now the natural question
that a systems worsen task is how
valuable is this stuff so what is the
difference between these so what I'm
showing you here is the cost per job and
there's basically two regimes that you
care about and so this is log CL done
roll over beta but this is low load or
low energy cost high load or high energy
cost and basically if you think of what
you're gaining from speed scaling this
is how much you're gaining and this is
interesting because it lets you look at
questions such as you know that result I
just showed you was for PS suppose I did
it for SRPT and we tried to look at how
much scheduling mattered in the worst
case result scheduling matters a lot it
matters by you know factor three or four
yeah so bado is the thing that for the
theorems is all one it's the weighting
of energy our side the weighting of the
life so the objective is beta times e of
T plus this so for the theorems it's all
one but here it's relevant so I brought
it back into things so now if you're if
you're looking at this you can prove a
lower bound and you can actually show
that in some sense there's not much room
to be gained from doing anything more
complicated than processor sharing and
this is you know born out when you look
at doing s every TV instead of yes so
you get very very small gains from on
the particular instances once you're in
this de cast ik and it's even worse than
that in the sense that if you didn't
want to do dynamic speed scaling in the
way I've described it and all you wanted
to do was turn off the server when there
were no jobs present and when it's on
have a constant speed so this is called
gated static so you know don't do
anything complicated you just say I'm
gonna turn it off and I'm gonna run at a
constant speed but I'm gonna be a little
bit smart about how I pick that speed
then you're basically the same gain a
little bit from doing the very
complicated speed scaling that you know
spent all this time so far talking well
but not very much at all
and this you know brings us back to my
theme of robustness versus optimality
because if all you care about is you
know a small epsilon approximation in
the stochastic model there's no reason
to do full-on dynamic speed scaling just
pick an optimal speed and turn off when
there are no doves present but if you
care about robustness there's a huge
reason to go after these more
sophisticated schemes and so to drive
that home what I'll do here is I'll show
this is the real row I picked a system
where the row the load was tenth but
we'll imagine that you don't know that
and you have some estimate of it and
that's what's on this axis so if you do
the optimal stochastic control and you
know the row it's the best but if you're
off there's kind of this degradation
where depending on how far you're off
your cost is worse and so your
robustness is you know captured by how
much this increases compared to what it
is at optimality which is here if you do
gated static you're really really
fragile like if you underestimate that
speed you can be in state and you know
if you underestimate the road you can
load you can be unstable
if you overestimate you overestimate you
pay really quickly and now you know the
worst case model is basically here so
the worst case model corresponds to you
know not we don't care what their Lotus
there's no load in that model and it
turns out that it aligns in this case
exactly with the row equals zero case
right because the in the quadratic case
the optimal stochastic control was Rho
plus root n the worst case control was
root n and so they aligned here and so
you basically it's as if you just chose
row equals zero and you tried not to
estimate it you were really conservative
and
so this is kind of the story so you have
robustness here where you don't depend
on the load at all but you pay in terms
of optimality and this may be large or
here and the nice case about speed
scaling is you know that strong
connection we had between you know the
form of the control and the two models
lets you actually prove results that
combine them directly so this was the
result from I guess but it's 2011 and so
this is just for the quadratic case but
we can do it more generally what you the
the exercise is to imagine designing a
policy that's optimal for some estimate
of the load so you're gonna estimate the
load in the system
you're gonna design the optimal
stochastic control policy for that but
you want to know how robust it is so you
want to know the competitive ratio for
that policy and then you're going to use
this to decide how to control for both
your sub optimality and your robustness
so what you can do is you can prove that
if you designed your system for load row
your two row plus two competitive so in
some sense it gives you a direct
comparison between how accurate you are
in your row so that you know the
difference between this and the true row
gives you how off you are for the
optimality and this gives you your
robustness guarantee and you can
trade-off explicitly between optimality
and robustness because you can combine
in some sense the worst-case results for
the stochastic policies
Yeah right and there there's no max
because if you ask to underestimate row
there you know the competitor ratio
would be infinite because if you
underestimate it's unstable and so so
any of the discrete settings anything
that's not as robust you you can't you
don't get a nice constant here but you
know here you get a robustness bound
that depends on your your estimation for
oh and in some sense this highlights
exactly why you should be conservative
in your estimate for a load in these in
setting these stochastic models because
if you're conservative it helps you with
robustness if you're aggressive it hurts
you with robustness it's a natural next
question will feed that I mean can can
maybe like an policy that only looks at
just the speed at two levels of yeah
yeah yeah so can you you know can you do
something where your two levels or n
levels and still maintain something like
this I don't know it's a great open
question another one is can you get
something that is independent of row can
you have a policy that it has an
optimality guarantee in the stochastic
model but has a robustness guarantee
independent of row no result that I know
there yeah so the only way this result
assumes polynomial I don't know how to
do it beyond polynomial it's pretty
sensitive so you get you get something
that's growing in alpha here that would
be another thing that would be nice to
reduce
okay and so you know in this case you
get a twenty two two and six and so you
could actually trade off and be you know
within one and give home you have a six
so is it needed all these sorts of
things the one comment I'll make on this
is if you only care about robustness
within the stochastic model not worst
case for Busta's there is something you
can do and it's interesting because it
means moving away from energy
proportional computing so if if you're
you know you give up on worst case
entirely but you want to be robust
within M G one type of sumption z-- then
linear scaling can be too competitive
and not use the row at all so you don't
have to ask me row you're always within
a factor of two of the optimal but it's
under stack a stack assumptions still
and this is the sort of result that I
love to see at connecting the worst case
and the stochastic model this is pretty
weak and this is really you know this
doesn't hold beyond quadratic this is a
really baby sort of result but it's an
indication that maybe something's
possible okay good so that's basically
the end of what I wanted to say on speed
skating but I want to highlight that you
know results like this are interesting
jion's be scaling pretty much pick your
scheduling question there's a disconnect
between optimality results and
stochastic models and robustness results
and worst-case models and finding a way
of trading off between those is
something that you know I know if
basically this result in one other one
okay so the second one I want to do is a
complete change of pace on two tails and
the idea here is instead of trading off
between robustness and optimality with
the like deriving a trade off I want to
say okay we can't do well in this
situation but can we understand better
how to design an adaptive policy how to
learn where the hardness is coming from
by combining the insights from the two
types of analysis okay and so here a
tail so what do I mean by tails this is
this is like the 95 95th percentile of
performance 95th percentile of delay so
instead of caring about the mean as
everything that Nikhil did and
everything that I've timed so far does
we look at these retail this is this is
the measure of interest really for most
systems doing well in the mean is nice
but really all QoS guarantees are about
a 95th percentile or the 99th percentile
and it is not what you care about and
there's a nice that's one motivation the
other next motivation again comes from
the Google folks and you know they have
this nice paper just a couple of years
ago on the tail at scale and basically
the perspective is now everything that
you're doing in Hadoop or you know these
big multi parallel systems if you're if
all your jobs are running in a hundred
peril servers then the 99%
you know bad event happens every time or
almost every time and so that's the
bottleneck now so in rather than being
something that happens rarely it happens
on every job every time and so you have
to control the tail to do anything so
again you know older faster is better
minimize the meme now cut off the tail
and so again you know SRPT is optimal
and robust for the mean and you hope for
something that's optimal and robust for
the tail it seems like a small change
basically the answer is no you can't
hope for that you can't do well for the
tail and you know that's the short
answer and I'll get the long answer so
so that's the short answer now the long
answer what do we even mean when I say
optimizing the tail so what what so what
do you mean control the tail and so
there's basically two long you know two
lines of work in this so you either
focus on minimizing higher moments
variants third moment etc or the lp
norms of response time as a general way
of saying that or you focus on the tail
but you can't and you can't really focus
on the you know 95th percentile so you
focus on the decay rate of the tail or
the asymptotics of the tail and
basically you know this is the focus of
the scheduling community this is the
focus of the queueing although there are
some queuing results up here too but of
course this isn't something you can look
at in the worst case model there's other
things but but these are really the two
big ones and so starting with the LP
norm because worst case is more familiar
and the story here is shorter the
basically the story here is no policy
can do well you are in summer your worst
case you get you know order and
competitive policies it's the best you
can hope for and this is Nikhil's result
and you know that's kind of it but you
know just like with blind policies a
little extra capacity goes a long way
and so if you give yourself one plus
epsilon speed you can be one over
epsilon competitive
okay so there's lots of people that have
a long line of work on these some of
which are in the room but maybe the more
you know the question that is
interesting coming out of that is why is
it so hard to be robust for healthy
norms I mean we can do well for the mean
why not for
and I think you know you see examples
right clearly these proofs have you know
some instance that the algorithms do
badly on but when you give one instance
as a lower bound for proof it's very
fragile right it's hard to learn
something about really what the
underlying hardness is from I mean I was
quizzing the keel about this yesterday
to see if you had some intuition about
say exactly a single server model that
we talked about no this is just worse
case so that this is worst case yeah so
these are worst case results now we're
gonna go to stochastic though so now
other questions can maybe the stochastic
model give some insight as to into why
these are actually hard and maybe
something that you can do to learn about
dividing around these yeah for
everything okay so in the stochastic
case this is actually a region where we
can do G G so we can be pretty general
with these because all we're looking at
is the limit for the tail we don't care
about exact analysis it's already
approximate and so we can do arbitrary
or stochastic arrival process arbitrary
job size distributions here I will care
about load being less than 1 since we're
not controlling the speeds and you know
the goal is to minimize the asymptotic
of the tail and basically the first step
here is to realize there's two regimes
of interest basically either things
behave exponentially or things behave
polynomially and you can't analyze them
in the same way and different things
happen in these two regimes and so
basically as soon as you have light tail
job sizes your distribution is going to
be something that decays exponentially
as soon as you have heavy tailed or
polynomial job sizes then your response
time is going to be polynomial as well
and so you need different tools
different techniques in both cases and I
think something that'll be nice to pull
out for especially the worst case folks
here is well so these are the particular
ones I mean so is that the intuition
across these is very different and so so
what I like to sort of pitch here is
that in some sense when you're thinking
about this type of large deviations
analysis you're basically studying
conspiracy theories and when you think
of the heavy tails you're thinking about
catastrophes and this intuition gets you
a long ways in analyzing policies in the
static model and also in
and so I don't think it's as familiar to
you guys so to get you an idea of what I
mean by conspiracy and catastrophe so
here's a little thought experiment
so suppose you know you're giving
lecture your 50 students for kicks you
do a poll you ask them to write down
their heights you ask them to write down
how many Twitter followers they are and
then you sum them up okay and so turns
out that the sum of heights is something
maybe 300 feet and a sum of Twitter
followers is like a million so both are
pretty weird numbers right so these are
extremes something strange happened to
get 50 people that have heights you know
that's some over 300 means that you know
the average is over 6 feet something
strange happened you know it's rare I
don't know how many Twitter followers
you guys all have but I doubt we'd get
to a million in the circle and so you
know something weird happened right and
if you think about why you know now do
the thought experience so so why what
could have led to this so with the
heights
well maybe Twitter first so with the
Twitter followers if you know in this
room if this happened it's because
somehow some somebody here is a syllabus
you know Twitter celebrity there's one
person that probably has a million
followers and the rest of us have our 10
and then that's that
right right
but here that doesn't happen right
there's not some giant that's 290 feet
tall and the rest of us so you know in
this case probably like the volleyball
team or the basketball team was in the
room they were all really tall and you
know that drove it or is here you know
it's a celebrity so so this we have a
catastrophe right there's one really big
bad event and here there's a conspiracy
there's a lot of slightly larger than
average events that combine to make the
railroad this is conspiracy versus
catastrophe and this underlines all of
it and you can formalize this so you can
formalize mathematically what this means
by a conspiracy principle and a
catastrophes principle and use them and
proofs directly so I you know just to
make it a little bit more mathematical
in the example and I like this plot a
lot in terms of driving at home so why
Bowl distributions hopefully everybody's
heard of them maybe not so
No so live alone nobody knows like well
who knows libel just other curiosity
good that's some so libel is a nice
distribution because it can be both
heavy-tailed and light tailed just by
setting the parameter so if you set its
shape parameter or less than one it's
heavy tailed if you set it equal to one
it's an exponential if you said it
bigger than one it's light tailed okay
and so it's a nice thing for comparing
the two distributions if you know if you
take that away that's one thing you
learn from the talk so that's good
and so let's take two Weibull samples
and we'll you know both mean one and
we'll assume that a rare event happened
you added them up and the sum was some
really large number d now as a basic
probability test for you so if it's
exponential so why Bowl with parameter
one and you know that the sum was d
what's the marginal of x one a nice
probability property of exponential is
that then x1 is uniform between 0 and T
so so there you know once you know that
the sum of them is D they're both
uniform either one could be large
they're basically the same everything's
nice and simple now I push it to the
light tailed very sorry I think I do the
heavy tail I push it to a heavy tailed
version of libels I can see a
catastrophe principle so once you have
the heavy tailed version of libels one
of those was d one of them was here
basically do u minus epsilon and epsilon
with extremely high probability I push
it to the light tailed version they were
both right at the mean so this is what
we always use in Rio our randomized
algorithms concentration inequalities
right we have a large sum they're both
close to the mean you know there we go
wait I mean I guess I shouldn't say mean
they're both close to half of D all
right
and so very different behavior and go so
here you have a conspiracy they're both
much larger than their mean because the
one would be down here but they're both
are contributing to the bad events
whereas under something heavy tailed
only one contributes to the right events
so formally this is what you can mean
you can write them down as so they're
you know there's two versions that are
both useful for a catastrophe principal
the max has the same you know asymptotic
says the sum or given the max is larger
than T or size probably the max is
larger than C given that the sum is
larger than T goes to 1 that's a
catastrophe basically 1 you know a large
sum is large because one thing in the
Sun was large and this happens under
things like paredo sub libels log
normals things like that conspiracy
principle is the opposite and it's the
more net more intuitive version if the
max is large sorry the probability that
the max is large is larger than T is
much less likely order of magnitude less
likely than the probability that the sum
is large so catastrophe Rachel we're
using all the time what I'll show you
how to use it for in a second is you
know principal of single big jump is is
basically the way it comes up and
queuing a lot where you know because you
know if the workload got large it was
because one really bad thing happened
one really large job arrived but
generally the catastrophe pinchable is
you know associated directly so it's
one-to-one with sub exponential
distributions which are defined in this
way so these are equivalent takes maybe
five lines to prove it but too hard and
they encompass basically every
heavy-tailed distribution that you've
heard of so if you've heard of it if it
has a name it sub-exponential it's not
all of them there are things that are
heavy tailed that are beyond that and
actually I'll end my talk on Friday long
tailed distributions will come up so
it's a little but everything that you've
heard of is still exponential
okay so that's conspiracy versus
catastrophe now I want to give an
example of how you use them
so we'll do FIFO just because it's easy
to do here and so we'll start with heavy
tail just catastrophe is more fun so the
the tail asymptotics of heavy tail look
like this and I didn't write down
attribution because I it's basically one
of these results that's just been known
forever so Nikhil did the residual I
used X re x whereas instead of XE but
this is the residual that he talked
about connecting to the inspection
paradox this remember was the number of
jobs in the system as the expectation
and so this has some nice meaning in
terms of intuition but but I won't dwell
on that too much so it's waiting and
it's waiting time instead of response
time residual job size the only thing
I'll say is that this is really bad so
that so it's hard to tell without
context this is this is a bad result
this is actually the worst case that you
could have for your tail isotonix
because it's if you think of things as
being polynomial remember this was the
definition that Nikhil gave it's you
know if you integrate a polynomial in
this way you're getting something that's
one degree heavier than the job size
distribution you'd like to be scheduling
things so that the tail was matching the
job size distribution this is a whole
degree heavier this means it has one
less finite moment so this could mean
something where you're mean was finite
in the tail you know this is really bad
so this going to be
this is a bad news result and it's in
fact not just bad it's the worst
possible so proving it though the the
one reason the result that's maybe the
most direct to what I've told you about
conspiracies is this this proof so you
have to trust me on this queueing result
it's a beautiful queueing result it says
that the workload in the system can be
decomposed into just a geometric number
of residuals and so this actually comes
from doing an analysis of processor
sharing that's quite nice and uses
reversibility and things like this but
it's our very classic result so take
that as given and now once you have that
you can write down the tale just
directly from this you know I saying as
1 minus Rho times Rho to the end from
the geometric times the probability that
this sum is large the test rafi
principle is about sums so I just now
apply it directly to that sum and you
know the catastrophe tale principle
tells me that this sum is large because
one of them was large and now I just
compute and I'm done
okay so it's sort of directly not so
intuitive but you know it's directly
thing more sample path one and so this
one requires this which is mg sample
path you can get to G G and here use
this principle was singled your big jump
that I talked about so here the way to
think about is what has to happen for us
to have a lot really large delay for a
job well it means that the workload has
to be really large at some time that a
job arrived right so a new arrival at
time zero has to wait behind all the
work that was there so for the waiting
time to be large this has to be large
well how could that have gotten large
well one way it could have gotten large
is that at some time in the past a
really big job arrived and on the
surface this seems like a ridiculous
thing to try to do a proof on but
catastrogue principle tells you that
this is basically enough this is the
dominant event there's you know if you
can analyze this event everything else
will concentrate around it and so that's
all you do you say I'm gonna consider a
simple path where a really big job
arrived how big well work gets done at
rate you know work will get cleared out
of the system at rate 1 minus Rho T
because wrote new work is coming in at
Roma Rho T so I need that job to be X
plus 1 minus Rho T sighs and since it's
really large you know law of large
numbers will kick in and this will be
exactly right for what we need we'll get
tight concentration around it and so we
just have this big jump and that's it so
you know it's a little bit of work to
give your upper and lower bounds but
basically you write down this equation
which says that I need some job to have
arrived at some point in the past that
was this big I integrated over the
different times that that job could have
arrived I do two lines of calculus and
I'm done now you know the lower bound is
really easy because this is one way it
could have happened there are many other
ways it could have happened so bounding
the fact that those don't contribute too
much mass is where you use some
concentration stuff but this is the
argument
that's catastrophe and you can see it's
really useful so now you know if you
ever have a heavy-tailed queuing system
or heavy tails come up you just you know
this is the intuition a bad thing
happens because one really large thing
happens and you know as long as you're
heavy tails are sub-exponential that
lets you do the analysis directly based
on that principle conspiracy is much
more familiar so this is the way that
you all do your concentration results
for randomized algorithms so the results
here tend to be a little bit more I
guess more difficult to parse and so
this is what the tail index looks like
it's the soap this is mg a moment
generating function of the inter rivals
this is a moment generating function if
the job size is it's not so important
what it looks like but it's optimal so
in the in the heavy tailed case it was
the worst possible tail here it's the
optimal tail that first-come-first-serve
obtains and you know what I want to say
here about the proof is just to connect
it to the conspiracy principle and to
make sure that everybody's here has
heard of Kramer's theorem so you know
turn off bounds we of course you've used
before for these sorts of analysis in
queueing use Cramer's which is just the
straight the strengthened version of it
so you know you don't need a bount
you don't need just a bound you need the
tight asymptotics and so you can get the
tight asymptotics with basically the
same form as long as you just look at
the limit rather than look at the finite
bound okay so once you have that you
know the one maybe the the second post
one of the most famous queueing
equations is Lindley's recursion maybe
second after littles law which somebody
already asked a question about so this
just says that the waiting time under
first-come first-serve for the n plus
first job is can be written in a nice
recursive way based on you know the
waiting time that you had for the nth
job plus well the size of that or that
new arrival minus the time the inter
arrival time the time since the previous
jobs arrive right this is you know how
much this was how much work was done
before you arrived then you added this
to it so this is the new workload and of
course it has to be positive this kind
of design defines the whole dynamics of
the workload for a queueing system in a
nice simple recursion and you can you
know get rid of the positive part by
looking at the max of subsequent sums
where the sums are over the X I - de-ice
the gap between the inter-arrival in the
x's and now you have something that
looks pretty nice so you have this
probability that's the max of sums and
so Union bound or you not even about it
bound the max with the sum and now you
can apply Kramer's to the internal some
contraction principle to the whole thing
which basically says that the sum is
going to be bounded the tail of the sum
is going to map to the smallest decay
rate of any piece of the sum and the key
thing is that you get your conspiracy
principle here because which of these
sums is kind of dominate basically
you're going to get a dominant sum that
includes some intermediate end and that
intermediate end means some combination
of a certain number of jobs was a little
weird so you have a large queue length
not because there was one big arrival
but because there was some sequence of
you know an intermediate jobs which
combines to make things bad for you so
you basically get exactly the conspiracy
from understanding what this minimizer
of the this contraction principle looks
like
okay so with that in mind so we did
first come first or we did FIFO and FIFO
is worse possible in heavy-tailed
optimal and light tailed now we're going
to get back to the connection with it's
impossible to be robust because if we go
through the laundry list of scheduling
policies you'll see that they're all
either worst case in light tailed and
optimal and heavy tailed or vice-versa
so if you were to do the same analysis
for SRPT
you would get worse possible for light
tailed optimal for heavy tailed s ETF
the best you know that blind policy that
Nikhil talked about worse possible over
here optimal over here you can go down
the list basically every policy you've
heard of has been analyzed and it is
optimal or worst-case in both and
nothing is is good across both of these
regimes and so it begs the question can
a policy be optimal for both and of
course the easy answer to this question
is yes you just learn the workload and
if you know the workload you use the
right policy for that workload not very
satisfying to a worst-case crowd I would
imagine but you know so the more natural
kind of static policy be optimal for
both and here the answer is no so and
it's because of the inability to control
for catastrophes and conspiracies at the
same time so you can take exactly that
intuition about catastrophe versus
conspiracies that I was giving you and
prove that no online static policy can
be optimal for both heavy tailed and
light tail job sizes and the proof is a
bit technical it's it's a you know it's
it's a pretty detailed change of
measured kind of argument but the
intuition is pretty simple so to do well
in heavy tailed you have to control for
the catastrophe which means what does
that mean it means that if an infinite
size job arrives you need to make sure
that it doesn't make things unstable
because if it makes things unstable then
all the other jobs will suffer and you
know so under first-come first-serve in
if an infinite job arrives nobody else
after that jobs finishes so the system
becomes unstable and you know that that
is turns out to be a necessary
condition for being optimal and heavy
tailless you have to make sure that if
an infinite size job arrives things take
stable under SRPT an infinite size job
doesn't affect anything right so an
infinite sty job just sits at the back
of the queue the whole time it only gets
work when no one else is present
everything finishes nicely so that's
necessary here but under light tailed
you actually have to make sure that no
matter what every job gets served at a
sufficient rate where sufficient is
proportional to a size and so and that's
basically to make sure that no
combination of jobs that are a little
bit larger than normal can cause
instability and clearly you can't do
both at the same time
why acerbity is more so yeah so that's
true I didn't I didn't give you any
intuition for that so it so it doesn't
work because so what's what's the good
intuition so think of think of the
exponential case and what the tale of
SRPT looks like the large job under SOP
team is going to have a much worse
behavior than the you know the large job
under first-come first-serve okay so
that's pretty clear and now the tale of
waiting time is going to be impacted by
the those large jobs and it's going to
be in Japan and impacted dramatically
right because they're going to get
stretched out quite a bit and so there's
one of the one of the intuitions is that
if you satisfy this your tail is going
to behave like a busy periods tail and
if you satisfy this then your tails
going to behave like a workload tail and
first come first serve the paves like a
workload which means that I'm gonna
light tail that does well but under
heavy tail it does bad and SRPT behaves
like a busy period which means that
under heavy tail since the busy period
doesn't depend on the higher moments it
does well but under it's confusing yeah
we can talk more after okay so so the
the thing that I think I want to
highlight the most about this is I think
this impossibility result is an upper
because what it highlights is it tells
you a lot about the structure that leads
to the bad you know the ability to have
robustness in the worst-case results and
it gives you an idea of how to learn you
don't actually have to learn too much to
do well and these sorts of learning
results so in the stochastic model the
the follow-up to that impossibility that
I just mentioned is actually that all
you need to do is learn the load and you
can be optimal in both most of the time
so you don't need to learn the tale you
don't need to learn some complicated
thing about the distribution you need to
learn the load and then you need to
share and basically do a hybrid of PS
and first-come first-serve where the
hybrid depends on the load so that you
make sure that each side can maintain
stability appropriately and so learning
something very simple can get you
robustness within the stochastic
framework and you know I I think that
you should be able to take this
intuition and do something like this
again in the in the worst case framework
what is it that is enough to learn about
the instance to be able to get around
the hardness results around LP norms of
these other things I think there's a lot
of insight in these sorts of arguments
that can connect to the risky
okay so that's basically what I wanted
to say there and you know I think
conspiracies and catastrophes really the
ideas that controlling for both of those
is very hard and this is again something
that we looked at in terms of tails but
it shows up in lots of other scheduling
problems and I think there's insights
there that can connect between the worst
cases up there Thanks I think before
taking questions up quick reminder there
is a lightning talk session open
problems and the research so you should
come back for that and if you yeah I
hope of some kind of general result
translating certain arguments from one
of the worlds oh yeah so the closest
thing we have to that is Nikhil's and
stuff that he talked about at the end of
the first talk where if you can
understand a busy period then you can
port the end to a-1 minus row and it's
in a sort of simple models I think
there's a lot left to try to do there in
terms of more general models but that's
hard so I've been thinking about the
multi server model of that for a little
while and it's really hard to to
understand busy periods and some of the
more general models in a tight enough
way that lets you do this porting but I
think that's a really interesting
direction where there's some nice
results the first part here I think it's
not a general framework but it's a
general style I'm sorry this is a second
one I guess number two on this list if
there's a general style of result that I
think we're missing that is very
interesting which is competitive results
for optimal stochastic policies or for
forms of stochastic policies and are
there problems where there's still a
strong competitive results for something
that is motivated by an optimality and
so I think results of the flavor you
know this is within a factor of X under
stochastic assumptions and
a worst-case guarantee that I think can
be done in some times with techniques
that we have but it's a different style
of question to ask than we've been
asking and then I think heavy versus the
light is something that should impact
worst-case results more than it has
questions
that's a great question I haven't seen
anything like that in the tale site so
there's no there's basically no
stochastic results anywhere that say you
know give yourself extra capacity how
how much do things improve and it's such
a common thing in the worst case world
would be nice to see them oh that's true
there's some for multiservice you're
right
okay so let's stop for coffee of them